- What was that?
(scary music)
(logo whooshing)
(logo squeaking)
You can buy a lot of
haunted things from eBay.
A lot of them are dolls,
most of them are dolls.
Another kind of haunted item you can get
from eBay is haunted jewelry.
I decided to buy a piece of
haunted jewelry off of eBay,
wear it, and see if I
experience anything paranormal.
I found a haunted bracelet.
The woman selling the
haunted bracelet said
she was a collector of haunted
items and haunted jewelry.
Nine years ago, she went to Italy
and she went to a flea market.
She went to a stand that
was selling antique jewelry.
And she said she felt energies coming
from some of the items
at the jewelry stand.
So she picked up this bracelet.
But when she picked it up, the Italian man
who was selling the jewelry
didn't want her to buy it.
He didn't really speak much
English, but apparently,
he said, "No good, cursed."
I guess my question is, if he doesn't want
anyone to buy this cursed bracelet,
why does he have it out
at his jewelry stand?
Why not keep it at home or get rid of it?
Maybe the curse is that
he can't get rid of it,
I don't know.
The woman tried to explain to the man
that she's a collector of paranormal items
and that she could
handle it, so she bought
the bracelet and took it home.
When she took the bracelet home,
it started showing up in
weird places around the house
where she definitely hadn't left it.
She said the temperature would drop
when she was wearing it
or when she was around it.
She felt like whatever
spirit possessed the bracelet
was trying to feed off her energy.
She said she wanted to get rid of it
'cause she felt like it
was possessed by an entity
that she didn't wanna deal with anymore.
The bracelet came in the mail.
I have it in this envelope.
Let's bust out this cursed bracelet.
Okay, it is smaller than
I thought it would be.
Don't be mad at me, ghost, I just thought
this was a bigger bracelet, okay.
So the woman who sold this bracelet
said she has no idea how old it is
because there's no markings on it.
I'm gonna wear it and we're gonna see
if anything weird happens.
So I actually do wish that
there was like a ghost
inside this bracelet to help me put it on,
because it's one of those bracelets
that's really hard to get
on without somebody's help.
I have placed the bracelet onto my wrist.
It's pretty hot in here, but this bracelet
feels oddly cold against my skin.
It feels very cold.
But it could just be because
it's super hot in here
that anything metal is going
to feel very refreshing.
I do like the tiny
people on this bracelet.
They're very cute.
- This looks like George Washington.
Oh no, am I going to be
cursed now that I touched it?
- [Joanna] I don't know.
- See, I just got a chill.
- [Joanna] You did?
- I legitimately just got like a chill.
- I've been wearing
this bracelet for maybe
30 minutes and I just feel so tired.
Something is stealing my energy.
I don't know if it's a ghost,
but I'm definitely tired.
Something super weird did happen to me
and I have no explanation for it.
Somehow, I got lipstick
all over my computer.
And I swear to God, I
did not kiss my computer.
It's not on my hands.
There's not lipstick on anything else.
I have no idea how I got
lipstick on my computer.
It's super weird.
I just got home, it's about eight o'clock.
I'm still wearing the bracelet.
Normally, I have a rule that I don't bring
haunted things into my
home, but I broke the rule
by wearing this bracelet,
so that's not great.
I'm definitely way more
tired than I normally am.
If there's a ghost sucking
my energy with this bracelet,
it's doing an amazing job.
I feel kind of relieved
to take off the bracelet.
It is nice to just stop
wearing an evil bracelet for the day.
So I'm definitely on
edge, being home alone
with the haunted bracelet.
Every time I hear any noise,
I'm just like, what was that?
I am hearing some very unusual noises
that I've never heard before.
Is there a weird vibration
going through the attic?
Which is not ideal.
I'm trying to just be chill about it,
but there's a cursed bracelet
just hanging out where I sleep.
Whenever I'm scared, I like to just
look out the window across the street
at my neighbors and I
can always see their TV
through the window and I'm just like,
okay, the neighbors are
watching TV, everything's chill.
I keep wanting to throw
the bracelet outside
every time I hear a weird noise.
This is why I don't bring
haunted things into the house.
Don't buy haunted bracelet.
I'm just recording where I'm leaving it
in case it's in a different
place in the morning.
I hope that it stays right here.
I thought maybe when
I woke up this morning
and came out to the living
room, I would see a ghost child.
And I did not see that, so
my bracelet, thankfully,
is exactly where I left it,
right on top of my wallet.
One of my cabinets is weirdly open
and I definitely didn't leave it open.
So either my husband or a ghost did this.
So I've had kind of a rough morning.
I'm wearing the bracelet.
I woke up 6:00 a.m. to
try to go to the DMV
to renew my driver's license.
My train was late and
it took way longer than it's supposed to.
Even though I got up two hours early,
to go to the DMV, I was
still two hours late to work.
So I don't know, is it
the curse of the bracelet?
I've been wearing this bracelet all day.
A few bad, weird things did happen.
Maybe this bracelet is cursed.
If you're scared of ghosts and
you wanna get over that fear,
buy something haunted from
eBay, like a bracelet,
hang out with it, and then
if nothing scary happens,
maybe you'll feel a
little bit less scared.
And then if something scary does happen,
you'll know that your fear was justified
and you'll feel smart for being afraid.
For the record, I'm never
bringing this into my house again.
(gentle music)
(logo whooshing)
(logo squeaking)